what is up everybody its Anna Mike here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about a pretty shocking
development in the black clover story a
brand new magic spell has just been
revealed and this type of magic could
potentially completely change the game
in black clover
this could throw the so-called stage
system or tear system completely out of
whack and what we just witnessed could
have major implications for how the
current arc in the story will ultimately
end there is a lot to talk about the
stakes have never been higher so let's
get into it if you enjoy the black
clover content on this channel please
leave I like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications a big thank you to
all of our anime our patrons who make
videos like this one possible with the
current global crisis YouTube has been
even less reliable than usual so your
help now means more than ever I'll talk
more about patreon at the end of the
video but please be advised that this
video will contain black clover manga
spoilers we're dealing with the most
recent events in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned as you will recall the previous
installment of the story and did amid
the high stakes battle between Locke
voltea and Sven Caen the Vanek assim a
man who i lovingly referred to as
simpkin at the beginning of their fight
simpkin had made it clear that luck
doesn't stand a chance against him
because luck is a stage one mage and
Simkin is a stage zero mage according to
Simpkins logic this means that he is out
of Luck's League and there is absolutely
no way the luck can win this fight hmm
more on that later the latest chapter
actually begins with a flashback to the
time skip period during which the clover
kingdom magic Knights were training
together with the spirit guardians of
the Hart Kingdom you will recall that
the Hart Kingdom mages use different
types of magic from the magic of the
clover
and the heart kingdom mages place a
special emphasis on harnessing the mana
of nature since gaia had said that the
heart kingdoms magic techniques work
best with nature based magic attributes
hasta brain's lock a lightning magic
user and magna a flame magic user to be
trained by gaia himself guy agrees but
he says that first and foremost the
mages need to learn to create runes from
natural mana if they cannot create these
rune circles they will not be able to
harness the mana of nature this rule
magic was first revealed to us back when
Gaia was introduced to the story and
since then we've seen a number of mages
successfully using it however it turns
out that while Locke has a natural
instinct for rune magic Magna is unable
to learn this type of magic because his
mana is just too low Magna is apparently
a stage 5 mage and in order to use rune
magic you need to be at least a stage 3
Magna walks out angrily and says that he
will just get stronger on his own
hasta feels bad for him but Locke tells
hasta to leave Magna alone luck says
that if this stops magna from getting
stronger then that is all that he was
worth and I thought that this was a
pretty epic friendship moment to be
honest and Shonen manga where friendship
is such a huge focus you would expect
Magnus good friend luck to also get
upset and to tell Gaia that he must
either train them both or Locke will
also refuse to be trained by him but
luck doesn't do that luck chooses the
more manly tough love option he believes
in his friend Magna and he knows that
Magna is strong enough to deal with this
situation to learn from it and to
overcome it Magna doesn't need anyone to
feel sorry for him or to show him
sympathy he will use this as motivation
and he will find some other way to get
stronger luck knows his friend well
enough not to underestimate his
strengths his resolve and his resilience
and I actually think that this is the
sign of a stronger friendship than a
friendship in which you feel like you
have to white knight for the other
person as Locke's training continues
Gaea teaches him that using
he can issue simple orders to magic such
as to pursue a target or to grow bigger
the more complex the runes the stronger
Lux magic can become but he has to come
up with an array or combination of runes
that best suits his own unique style
luck wants Gaia to teach him how to cast
his true lightning spell and Gaia
explains that this spell is exactly what
it sounds like it generates real
lightning and it took Guyot years to
master
Gaia tells locke that he specializes in
discharge spells while lux specializes
in equip spells so rather than just
discharging a bunch of lightning in
every direction lux strength lies in
focusing his magic on his hands and our
feet and then using his magic in that
way so Gaia advises luck to put his
new-found rune magic skills to work
alongside his equipment kills this will
play to his existing strengths and it is
a better strategy than trying to
outright copy Gaia spell now back in the
present time we get to witness how
exactly luck has been able to take guy's
advice and combine rune magic with his
own existing magical skills Locke has
shown clearly using various rune circles
in battle against sim King but at first
it appears as if Lux still isn't fast
enough to outmaneuver simpkins powerful
skin magic luck is apparently able to
use the runic circles as a sort of
springboard in midair he bounces off of
them when he attacks and they seem to
make him faster in fact he is actually
able to deal some damage to his opponent
stomach to Simpkins great surprise the
damage that Locke caused Simkin isn't
that great but the fact that he was able
to deal any damage in the first place
tells the villain that luck has been
able to increase his own speed beyond
the speed of Simkin skin detection as a
result Simkin decides to just fully
harden his skin right away which means
that no matter how hard luck tries to
hit him
Simpkins defenses are always going to be
at their max but while simpkin was busy
increasing his defenses Locke had
stacked five different rune magic
circles behind him and he then uses all
five of them at the same time to launch
himself
at his opponent this allows lock to
unlock true lightning magic and more
specifically a spell called true
lightning magic Sarah knows block is
seemingly able to increase his speed to
such an extent that instead of
discharging real lightning like Gaia
does Luck is actually able to turn his
own body into true lightning and so in
this state of pure lightning luck is
able to turn himself into a piercing
spear of lightning and punch right
through simpkins torso and as you can
imagine that is the end of that fight
using Hart Kingdom magic Locke has
basically become NL from one piece and
this really appears to be a whole new
level of power that Locke has just been
able to unlock this completely changes
everything we thought we knew about Lux
magic but more than that it also
completely changes everything we thought
we knew about the magic stage system
also known as the tier system remember
in the previous chapter how simp can
claim that the luck had no chance of
defeating him because luck was a stage
one mage and Simkin was a stage zero
mage well clearly that was complete BS
because by harnessing the power of the
rune circles and of true lightning luck
was able to absolutely annihilate a mage
who according to the stage system would
have been out of his league this tells
us a lot about luck himself and his own
drive and determination but it also
leaves the door open for many other
mages who have been identified as being
in the lower stages to actually surpass
their limits and defeat mages who stages
are significantly higher earlier in the
chapter of course we saw Gaia reject
magna because Magnum was only a stage 5
but after what luck just accomplished it
is entirely possible that magma and
other mages who have been underestimated
based on the stage system are going to
be able to get stronger in other ways
and so they may actually be able to
compete with mages who are considered to
be much more powerful on paper the fact
that luck who is not a zero stage mage
or an arcane stage mage was still able
to defeat a powerful dark disciple who
uses demon magic gives us hope that
other
characters like Noel will also be able
to put up a great fight against even the
strongest demons this development gives
hope to many characters who were
completely underestimated by the
villains up to this point and it opens
up new potential power boosts and
magical advancements in the near future
I was really intrigued and happy to see
this turn of events luck is an absolute
mad lad his magic is awesome and I
really want to see more of him in action
all of this stuff is setting up an
absolutely epic final showdown against
the dark triad and I can't wait to see
what happens next the dark disciples are
very strong but clearly they can be
defeated however the three members of
the dark triad are incredibly
overpowered and defeating them will be
extremely difficult but this new turn of
events involving Locke and true
lightning magic gives me hope that all
of our favorite black poles and other
characters will be able to get stronger
and launch a magnificent team attack
against the dark triad whenever the
final showdown does inevitably occur and
that is going to be absolutely epic and
you guys know how much I love when
teamwork comes into play and a bunch of
different unique magic all works
together for the same cause let me know
what you guys think were you impressed
by Lux newfound power and what do you
think this development means for the
future of this arc also if luck has
gotten this much stronger how much more
powerful do you think Noel has become
how much stronger is her water magic
after presumably training for six months
with the water spirit on Dean let me
know down below and man I really can't
wait to see post time skipped Noel in a
serious battle if you enjoyed this video
you want to see more please leave a like
to let me know it definitely helps and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking the bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you want to get to see our videos
if you don't do all of that which I know
can be annoying YouTube will bury our
videos and you won't
see them it's just the way it goes you
can also hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thank you to
baby ray and a friend a disciples of
Lord Twigg Oh himself and I can't forget
all our the one tear patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
in grata alone Adam the world stealers
the school bus Tyson quit Ino acquired
respect Pat a heffa Jonathan king deci d
and brandon Ovilus finally big thank you
to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
eldress Anatole Cassatt's key on he'll
crucify he's 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket XP
Ted no Ted Salter Joe Stanton very Gucci
Alisha actor animal as 69 jessica calif
on he no kami and water
Bonnie parks Zoey art 12 rasu Endora
Emperor otaku JCCC waka the coach and
Tendo if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value for you
please consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar gives you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]